you and i have talked about
some of your albums that you just kind
of put out just to get through your
contract
those weren't albums those projects
right just about what i put out
i'm claiming two two of my
albums as real albums and that's my
crazy life it's still crazy which or a
lot of people would say obviously your
two best albums but it could be but when
cuz i treated them as albums when i was
exactly and i feel like um you were
saying that you're you're having the
same approach with this new body of work
that's coming correct yeah i'm having
the same approach with everything i do
here on now because i'm in that space i
own all my [ __ ]
like you feel me i'm moving like it's
it's all on me it's my time i ain't got
no bad blood with like i ain't mad i
ain't
i don't feel no type of way it's just
like all right it's time to get busy you
know what i'm saying like you got
through the initial contract y'all did
my b
i did my as a new artist right that's
like kind of what usually happens like
yeah but i should have been i could have
been out my contract way before like
it's just like but you know what i'm
saying like
um
i guess like everybody around me we were
still learning this [ __ ] and then my
lawyers was saying some [ __ ] and had me
thinking this was the only way all this
type of [ __ ] so
you know
but the game got the best of me
for that time well what i like too is
your transparency because i feel like if
more artists are transparent about maybe
some of the shitty situations that
they're in
it
it will help like you know i feel like i
feel like it was the lebron [ __ ] you
were on the hbo [ __ ] well [ __ ] um
it was a no
that was a draymond green
but you guys were talking about like you
know how
thus far you haven't gotten any royalty
money from your from your catalog
because your old deal
and i think that's very important for
new artists to see because like
you know it's a predatory business for a
new artist who comes in the game and
signs yeah you come in a game you
you from the streets you ain't got no
business people around you who yeah i'm
saying help you punch him right there
you get that big advance and you're like
yo this has changed my life this amount
of money i ain't even get a big
advantage that's crazy ain't changed my
life